in 2013 the USDA Natural Resources
Conservation Service entered into a
cooperative agreement with the South
Dakota no-till Association and I grow
SDSU Extension for delivering the latest
soil health and productivity technology
to South Dakota farmers and ranchers a
series of two local events were held in
South Dakota in lemon and Fort Pierre
ok thanks Ruth when I pass these out I
have a handout if you already have it
don't worry about it but I want to make
sure everyone has that because I'm going
to refer to it a little bit in my
presentation now I'm going to be talking
about cover crops oh yeah I remember
that cover crops are just going to be
one component of that soil health system
do we talked about crop rotation
diversity no-till we have cover crops in
there as one component nutrient
management and integrated pest
management are the other two components
are that five component cropping system
designed for soil health we talked a
little bit about the Saline areas okay I
do have some soil test results from a
saline area right in that Lantry area
right around Ridge view east of RIT are
west of Eagle Butte zone ten is going to
be a very high saline area it's going to
be weight on the surface look how much
nitrogen is in the top two feet 1342
pounds I think that's enough to last for
a while I was kind of surprised with the
phosphorous they're not quite as high as
I thought it's 37 per per million down
below down here sodium 50 400 parts per
million sodium so yeah there's a lot of
a lot of different things in and those
those
saline areas sulfur maxed out on the
scale 120 and in 360 okay how you
mentioned before I mean just be talking
about one small component of the soil
health management system and just to
give you a quick definition of cover
crops to make sure we're all on the same
page any crop does plan between periods
of regular crop production to prevent
soil erosion provide organic matter
provide nitrogen the list goes on and on
and on and on and we'll cover more
here in a little bit but it's mainly
looking at that for you guys is going to
be looking at that intercrop period
where where it's gonna be wheat
harvested and then prior to the corn
planting time for the most part or oat
piece taken off for hay and then prior
to the following year's cash crop if
you're at all interested in cover crops
you need to go to this website either
order this book it's like 25 bucks or
you can download it in a PDF format it
is very valuable and it discusses a lot
of these species in great detail that
I'm going to be talking about throughout
the this presentation another
publication is overview of cover crops
and green manures you can access that at
this website there anywhere I give this
presentation of something similar we
talked about rainfall while you guys say
I'm way to go to plant cover crops and
we look at different periods throughout
the year as far as your your rainfall
goal is to determine that and I was kind
of shocked I mean again growing up just
south of Morristown I was shocked lemons
30 year average from 1971 to 2000 is a
little bit over 18 inches that shocked
me I I'm used to 1516 and if you look at
Macintoshes 30 year period it is an
exactly an inch eighty less than lemon
but eighteen point two four inches so
let's look at a couple of these inter
crop periods where the cover crops may
fit in and look at that rainfall period
or amount of moisture that is a received
in that period so when spring wheat
would stop using an appreciable amount
of water around August first again I
realize that could they could shift
anywhere from two weeks depending on the
year to win corn would start using an
appreciable amount of water twelve point
four inches or twelve point twelve and a
half inches of precip August 1st to July
1st for for spring wheat to sunflower a
little bit over 15 and a half
winter wheat to corn 13.8 16.9 for
winter wheat to sunflower so what's that
telling me is I think you do have a
decent amount of moisture be able to get
a cover crop growing in in that
situation now you got to remember when
you look at these preset values how much
does it show a hole how much can in the
top 5 feet how much water can that soil
hold plant-available water usually no
more than 11 inches and a lot of that's
going to be dictated by soil textures so
you're saying you're going to hold a lot
less of plants available water it's
going to be way less than that 11 inches
it's going to be around that 8 7 or 8
inches compared to the heavier soils you
you can't approach that 11 inches so
what I'm saying is your cup is
overfilled and you can you can spare a
little bit of wire to to grow a cover
crop and the reason the central part
state was was gung-ho on cover crops was
we were having a lot of trouble gaining
corn planted in the wheat stubble and
this is actually on Cronus farm this is
a field north west of Gettysburg it's on
really heavy clay soils it's actually
cells promise oils which would be
similar to Stanley County that they have
some ground up there and the one on the
right is where there was no cover crop
planted in there after the previous
year's wheat harvest compared to the one
on the left now they ran on a seed raid
in this area and they actually had to
quit planting this corn the spring of
2008 because it was just balling up the
planner they came back about ten days
later looking straight north and the
exact same spot through a little area
very little stand
corn stand there compared to where there
was cover crops so it allowed them the
traffic ability to get across that that
field timely another concern is well
okay it's using too much water and it
does it will use an inch to inch and a
half of water in the fall but by spring
when you're planting your next year's
crop what is it then and this is a
subsidy from North Dakota near Bismarck
this is on some fine sandy loam soils
where they had cover crop plants
available water was three inches no
cover crop 3.11
so very little difference when it comes
to planting corn difference for what
that cover crop used the fall before
so when we're selecting species you need
to know that your objectives are for
that cover crop on that particular field
what do you want it accomplished we'll
talk more about various objectives what
will the following years cash crop be
will it be corn will be sunflower that
was going to dictate of what kind of
mixtures you're going to want to be
planting or what species are going to
want to be planting for that for that
cover crop big one herbicide applied to
currents here's cash crop what did you
put on that wheat crop that may carry
over and damage that cover crop that's
another huge concern so again a big list
of objectives provide nitrogen add
organic matter improve motivate sustain
soil biology is a huge one huge one as
you learned earlier today review soil
erosion reduce compaction there's some
species four that are going to be better
that deeper compaction compared to
surface compaction manage nutrients
basically basically sequestered
nutrients bring up those ones that are
down in the root zone bring them up
closer to the surface provide weed
control that's a big one provide
livestock grazing is a huge one and
reducing soil salinity there's not a lot
of species though to be able to plant
and grow in those really white areas of
the field as I showed you earlier you're
going to basically be using that water
to keep that white area from growing any
larger but in the severe cases you're
better off with with perennials in that
in that situation just remember it
two-thirds of the organic matter comes
from the roots so don't get discouraged
if your cover crops four five six inches
tall you're still getting some some
benefit down below not only from that
sustaining that soil biology from moving
forward but also a little bit from some
organic matter that's being put into the
system and increasing soil how should be
the main focus for any crop plant system
sales have been mined for years under
tillage systems restoring soil
resilience is the key and dwyane hid a
lot about that on that earlier
why resource or resilience increase soil
organic matter again going back to that
biology keeping that thing sustained in
the live and movie improve water
infiltration decrease soil compaction
improve crop production or productivity
and just an impact we'll talk a little
bit more on some of this water and
filtration some on some aggregates
stability and so forth
I like showing these next three slides
here this is actually taken right south
of Isabel about ten twelve miles I
believe I took this on Labor Day of 2013
corn fuel bill as you can see or kind of
a poor cornfield but it was all burnt up
the history on this was and the field
I'll show you next this one it was CLP
for 20-some years it was taken out with
tillage it was farmed conventionally
with tillage a wheat there was the way
like a wheat sunflower millet crop on
there again all done with tillage new
operator took it over and fall of 2012
late fall 2013 he planted corn out there
you seen that very good cornfield and
very close by another cornfield was
taken out exact same time however it was
strictly done with no-till it was never
there was no disking or anything like
that going on a streak strictly Modi
servants no-till planting corn on both
of these fields and they're very close
together so he can't tell me that that
that CRP he didn't provide some some
benefit as far as long-term no tell
water infiltration and so forth of
what's taking place there so like
believe said carbon is is huge what we
need to do to mitigate mitigate drought
impacts your own up here we're always 5
to 7 days away from drought always don't
appear were about 14 days away from a
drought but here we're always very very
close to seem like we're always on the
edge so that carbon is huge in this area
especially and we need to include make
sure we include obviously greater than
50% Dwayne once that 75 to 80 percent
carbon into the system it's a fine line
there it just depends on your patch
nursery on a given field of
what's going to sustain you but greater
than two-thirds or greater would
probably be ideal alternate sequences
corn behind wheat corn behind soybean
corn behind fuel P and I know you guys
could raise some really good field peas
up here like to see some some some more
of those growing up in here eliminate
crop residue removal if you got to take
straw off of that for the livestock go
to the neighbors whatever neighbor isn't
here see if he can get his next year's
corn stalks or wheat straw or whatever
oat straw and use that because that's
that's something that's extremely
critical and if you're trained or hoping
to we have no more does that come in the
office that I always want to increase
their main objective is the increased
organic matter with these cover crops
you are out there and the wheat field is
all baled up I'm sorry to tell you
there's no amount of cover crop out
there that's going to to replace of what
he removed with that wheat straw no-till
with low disturbance openers and cover
crop at cover crops were possible but
monitor the percent brassicas you want
to talk more about that in a little bit
here so on some of those sheets that I
gave you a lot was handed out there's
some characteristics there but I try to
summarize some of these in these next
two tables of what species will do what
as far as objectives and really it's
just kind of kind of a bad government's
recommendation it's not it's nothing
science behind it but there's some
things that that we can observe there of
what what's good for what basically
compaction here a lot of guys see these
big radish ribs and they do do they do
do some good for some deep compaction a
lot of the surface compaction is better
off with some finer root systems and
that's where the rape is probably a
better fit if you have more surface
compaction and then some more the the
very very fine species out there like
teff produces a lot of fine roots and
they get into the real small areas that
break up mainly platy soil structure
moisture I'm not gonna worry about that
has more for over yeast where we try to
get try to plant some species that are
going to survive the winter and grow the
following spring to use more and more
yet over east nitrogen fixation
basically any of the other legumes out
there are you going to fix some nitrogen
some of them are a warm season versus
cool you need to keep that in mind
there's a lot of these warm season ones
if you're going to be planning after
spring wheat you're just wasting your
money they're going to die at 34 degrees
and not even get close to freezing at
all residue safety brassicas do a good
job of that and we'll talk more about
that in a minute nutrient cycling
anything to go down deep in that soil
profile and set up whatever nitrogen the
leftover salinity these species here the
barley sugar beet rape canola all handle
some salts fairly well rice should also
be in there so that pand all they gave
you there that frontpage is just the
characteristics of each of those species
we have identified four for NRCS
purposes you'll see the first seeding
leader listed on there for each of the
species and that's just there for if you
wanted to design a system let's say you
only want 20% of a species you just take
point two times that full seeding rate
to get 20% but the next two pages I put
together last year and I debated whether
or not to break it up into four
different regions or five different
regions across the state and I didn't it
was easier to do it this way but I
wanted I don't like to give you recipes
and our old standard our old way of
doing it we used to have premix is
already built in there well the mixture
I would recommend up here for a guy
would be completely different for the
guy down in the southeast part of state
but you could still use the similar
guide it's just going to have different
different percentages in there of each
of those types and I broke those species
into different types
you got the cool season broadleaf
legumes the brassicas cool season broad
leaves that aren't too legumes cool
season grasses etc there's a percent
range in there that I thought personally
I thought would be would be ideal for
meeting those objectives that you would
want to select
okay the Wunder cover crop more than
likely doesn't exist it'd be awesome if
we could just plant one it's going to
grow it's going to accomplish everything
we want but they just don't do well
singly so we're going to be looking at
mixtures and cocktails and a number of
you guys are piping up to Bismarck I've
heard Jay and Gabe preach that over and
over and we're seeing the same thing in
South Dakota now you need to look at
your crop rotation what are you missing
as far as a crop type is going to help
determine which species or which
dominant species are going to be planted
you always want to be planting even the
majority of your cover crop species need
to be an opposite crop type of next
year's cash crop so if you're planting
corn next year you want to have more the
majority of the species in this year's
cover crop be grasses no of course these
and Rowdies and some cool season
grasses should be in the majority of the
mixture you really don't want to put a
lot of the one season grasses in there
so again cover crop to be planted should
be an opposite type of cash crop to be
planted falling here so let's talk about
some of these brassicas you always hear
the word brassicas these are non legumes
and there's a number of them brassicas
and mustards so let's go through these
canola if you do any canola oil make
sure it's a winter type got law problems
with spring types going to seed
producing viable seed and some of that
viable specie is actually from Roundup
Ready canola so make sure it's a winter
type I prefer to use rape it's very very
similar to canola but it's actually
better for grazing rate that's better
than grazing then compared to canola
just because it produces more leafy
material and there's other hybrids out
there with turnips and rape and so forth
and we'll cover a few of those in a
minute
turnips another Brassica most common
ones going to be the purple top kernel
you're going to produce that round bulb
and I have a picture of that here in a
minute but most of those are the wrong
ball
there are some turnip varieties like
Barkin that is more of a radish type
looking root system the market is going
to be more of Forge more valuable for
Forge radish two main types I'll see the
Forge I have a picture on that in a
minute crabby kale Swede and then
mustards and we haven't dealt a lot with
some mustards one year we did some lady
mustard that decor Lakes and in mich or
in here on and that's leftist scum
bomber not to go and look really good it
produced a lot of biomass as I went to
see but I don't think it was viable seed
right you sprayed some of it because you
were concerned with that but you also
rolled some and then you left one strip
no I think yeah yeah I don't think you
sprayed much but you did do some my kale
is going to be the part of the cold
hardiest of Lamar's gonna tolerate
temperatures down in the single digits
for several nights in a row sweet is one
we really don't deal with unless it's
going to be a full season cover crop
something you're going to plant in the
spring it takes usually you don't want
to start grazing it for about 180 days
so it's one of those longer season ones
they're known for the rapid fall growth
great biomass production it produce a
lot of biomass but most of that's 85 to
90 percent water protein content on a
number of these brassicas are anywhere
from 12 to 18 percent depending on if
you're looking at the roots versus the
top growth so pretty decent protein
content they're assic excellent nutrient
scavengers you go deep and their
profiles suck up whatever nutrients are
left over pest management
characteristics most species release
chemical compounds that may be toxic to
soil borne pathogens and pests such as
nematodes fungi and some weeds mustards
usually have a higher concentration of
these chemicals here's 30 days after
growth left-hand sides
turnips these middle two are radishes
here then winter canola and then sugar
beet that's 30 days after planting sixty
days after planting here's your purple
top turnips
here's your radish dwarf s6 rape or
winter canola I guess
listed there and then your sugar beet so
you see the different root architecture
and again going back to deep compaction
versus surface compaction this was
probably better at surface compaction
and this one is probably a little bit
better at deeper compaction just a
illustrate what it can do
what brassicas can do for nutrient
scavenging at s and Western so Lee
County west of Oneida the cover crop was
planted August 18th
we split the field the soil test on it
right after planting where the cover
crop was at 88 versus 19 the top two
feet you would expect them to be the
same you could hopefully be the same and
they were you compare that in late
October went back out back out there the
soil sample um 112 pounds where there
was no cover crop compared to 18 pounds
where there was a cover crop left over
so that nitrogen is in is in that and
that cover crop biomass being protected
not able to leach down but it's going to
release throughout next year's growing
season and that's one of the questions
that a lot of the researchers are
working on for uni given area because
the soil moisture and temperature
dependent on how much of that nitrogen
is going to be released to next year's
cash crop we just can't come up with one
number it's going to be a range if
you're warm and wet it's going to be a
high percentage of that is going to be
released if you're too cold and dry it's
gonna be a very low amount looking at
manure they fit very well in a manure
application time setting or a period
these soil tests were taking in march
9th of or 2008 where there was cover
crop there was 49 pounds left over in
the top four feet compared to 233 pounds
in the top four feet where there was no
cover crop was that tell you they were
over applying to burner maybe a little
bit just to slide on fertilizing cover
crops a lot of guys you know we're
trying to minimize the input cost on a
lot of these species and the last thing
you want to do is throw more money yet
when your grant
however if you're planning on or hoping
to graze them you get that timing rain
right after planning you got an
excellent stand you're going behind
wheat you had a excellent wheat yield
your protein was less than 12 or lower
for low on the low side
you know you're short of nitrogen you're
probably going to want to throw a little
bit of urea or 28% out there to to get
some growth out there for biomass need
to be considering that as fertilizer for
next year's corn crop or whatever crop
you're going to the more you want out of
your cover crop the more it makes sense
to nurture the cover crop just some
examples on what cover crops can do for
weed control this is actually on North
Duane's north unit no cover crop on the
left the previous year this is in the
spring and the one on the right you see
how the eating weeds going out there
whatsoever no it's planted it was just
planted you know you said you had the
hard time hard slot to speak in to try
the one right after lunch this another
example we control of the guy was
planted a few cover crops over here on
the tree belt for hunting purposes went
across the field to empty out the drill
and and the rest of us didn't have it
you see the huge difference there for
weed control now a lot of guys get
intimidated we get guys will release
that do a lot of it just on prevent
plant acres and they see this big amount
of biomass out there and they're
wondering how in the heck am I going to
get out there next year the plant corner
of that stuff so they don't listen to us
on 1st thing you still go out there with
their big discs and working under
because they're still concerned but if
you happen to leave that it just melts
down especially if there's a lot of
brassicas in there and millstone -
absolutely nothing there's this nothing
leftist they said it's 85 to 90% water
even those big radish roots are just so
tender and mild and it really does it
there's no interference that whatsoever
a lot of guys worried about their
residue managers plugging up with these
big rash roots or
puts there's no way she's gonna cross
that and we talked about those residue
decomposes very quickly very low carbon
and nitrogen ratio and I said before a
lot of these tolerate cold temperatures
LOM will handle in that mid to upper
teens for several nights in a row if not
weeks in a row and be just fine and keep
growing here's an example of oil steel
as compared to forge raddish Forge
radish obviously after the name better
for livestock grazing more leaf material
produce and then I said there were
hybrids hybrids a turnip and rape called
Pasha hybrid of turnip and winter canola
called T Raptor and hunter hybrid have
turned up and kale called Winfred and
this is going to be since there's kale
in there it's gonna be extremely winter
or tolerance of cold temperatures and if
you're doing some late season grazing I
would definitely include some of that in
there now with these hybrids are a
little bit higher in seed costs seed
size is just a little bit bigger but for
the most part it's it's it's we still
use the same seeding rate and maybe
maybe we need to change on those but
I'll work with your your seed supplier
on some of those as far as some of these
hybrids and they can give you a pretty
good figure in there to include in that
mixture now remember that one slide I
said monitor your percent Brassica why
is that at the coal lakes in 2008 this
is picture taken in July this is on the
rotation on dry land when our wheat corn
fuel P rotation there was no cover crop
put in there there's actually corn grow
out there right now in 2008 but the
previous year after winter wheat there
was no cover crop planted Dwayne planted
several different treatments out there
some of them included a hard percent
Brassica and it would have been after
two years of wheat so this would have
been the cover crop would have been
placed right here two years a wheat look
at the bear gown July central South
Dakota you don't want that 25 to 30
bushel yield hit 100% brassicas not a
good plan so again as
West you're going to want to take this
sheet I gave you and monitor that
percent Brassica you don't want to go
over I don't think there's any of them
over there maybe for the wildlife one
there might be one that's 50% where all
the rest are at 40% it's zero to 40% so
throughout here you're gonna want to be
in that 25 to 30% at most four percent
brassicas brassicas like sulfur so if
you're following corn behind that or
even spring wheat behind a certain
property had cover crops in I've seen
sulfur deficiency in both of those crops
you're going to want some salt sulfur
out there I don't care what your soil
test says just leg Anthony I don't rely
on sulfur soil tests at all I think
personally I think it's more of a
sampling error than it is testing the
air but maybe maybe I'm wrong there
you're gonna want some sulfur out there
depending on how you put it on that
surface supplied you're going to want to
about 25 pounds 20 to 25 if it's banded
you can get by with that 8 to 10 maybe
12 pound range okay let's switch gears
the cool season broadleafs non legumes
sugar beet flax camelina sugar beets are
tolerate or tolerance to salinity
residue decomposes quickly good tap
right palm is germination is very very
poor at least we get the rejects from
the seed companies and I have yet to be
able to find a seed that you get a real
good establishment off of sugar beets so
I had quit recommending them but it's
still one out there that if you happen
to get a good seed supplier and the
quality is good that germ is good I
throw some in especially if you're
looking at trying to address some
salinity and cows just love these they
love them
pardon she do - okay fact small seed
produced tap red does not tolerate
quality drain soils or those high in
soluble salts fairly tolerant to frost
once once established and it's one facts
is very mycorrhizal
I started including a little bit of flax
and ever and every mixture when in
camelina we did a little bit of work
with us
in the Watertown area like its name says
it's winter we're hoping that to survive
the winter take off early in the spring
it's a broadleaf we're trying to look at
that opposite cover crop going to corn
and we had limited limited success we
had some come back but it was just I
don't know I just maybe we need to
revisit that again but we tried to work
with some guys on it and it didn't do
overly well it should but it didn't
Christi's and broadleaf legumes we've
got a whole host of them elfelfa sweet
clover could be probably in that warm
season one but we had red clover white
clover else eight clover hairy vetch
calm and veg notice two vetches very
very different very important to know
the difference
hairy vetch versus common veg crimson
clover chickling vetch third vetch feel
pea and lentils the clovers I'm not
going to talk a lot about these these
are more more over East the sweet clover
might have some fit here only thing I
don't like about sweet clover 50% or
more hard seed a gift that keeps on it
keeps on giving hairy vetch a little bit
of hard seed in there but the seed size
is very similar to wheat so it's hard to
get separated out it's one live not
quite as bad sweet clover it's one of
those that will keep seem like you plant
at once and you have it for the next 15
years so I'm very hesitant I only
recommend this the guys that I really
really know well that they'll do a good
job and controlling that volunteer
because it will overwinter this one will
overwinter well almost all the other
ones I covered here for the most part
will not overwinter the frost will kill
them out for the most part we've had
some dwarf Essex rape overwinter and
very mild winters and if you're going to
corn you need to be mixing a
sulfonylurea in with your burn Dahl do
not do a roundup Banville roundup 2 4 d
it will not work it may look like it
will work for 14 days but it will not
work make sure you throw a little bit of
Express or Harmony SG in there to take
care of that but hairy vetch will
overwinter
just a picture of that crimson clover
again more for over east picture that
chickling vetch i like this one a lot
produces a lot of nitrogen it's actually
one of that the organic farmers grow a
lot of it it it fixes a lot of nitrogen
very quickly it's draw parent only
problem seed costs aside seventy five
cents a pound so if i know the guys not
going to grieve because some of these
can be toxic to cattle and sheep and
it's mainly if it produces seed it's not
the vegetative portion that is toxic
it's mainly the seed but in some cases
if you happen to plan it get it planted
early it doesn't take long for them the
flower and maybe produce a little bit of
seed so you got to be watching there so
if the guys don't raise graze that i
recommend a little bit in the mixture
but i'll dilute it out with some other
cheaper legume species like common vetch
like lentils those sorts of things and
and and there's a picture of chickling
vetch also known as grass pea i don't
have a picture in here of in the end
chickling vetch tolerates or handles the
competition from these big leaf
brassicas very well so it does a really
good job in there that's just a picture
of the mixture there there's lentil in
there radish door 4-6 rape and chickling
vetch I don't have a picture of the few
peopie like few peas a lot but somewhat
similar to chicken and veg to see can
get kind of expensive because their
seeding rate for a few peas I believe
you look on the sheet I think it says
seventy pounds so even if you're doing
twenty thirty percent of that the seed
costs gets up in a hurry a lot of these
I'll do a small portion of the species
that are really light depending on what
cost is and then I'll do loot it out
with some cheaper ones but they're in
the same family there they're still a
cool season legume lentils a lot of
rentals out there Indian has red berries
Rose town Morton's are some of the
common ones smaller seed results in
cheaper cost they're a little bit slower
growing and not as aggressive most of
these legumes
lively you won't really
see very robust early on depending on
how much free nitrogen you have left
remaining in the soil you we don't see
these coming on until mid mid-september
so before they really start taking off
it's a picture of Indian Head lentils in
Gettysburg warm season broad leaves
legumes warm season broadleaf cow peas
soybeans non legumes sunflowers and
buckwheat safflower should be listed
there also although safflower is kind of
on the edge of cool and warm
buckwheat short season crop residue
decomposes quickly excuse me not as well
tolerant scavengers nutrients phosphorus
that are unavailable to other crops and
what Mike was alluding to earlier this
morning it actually releases a slight
mild acidic exudate from its root system
and anytime you throw an acid in the
soil is actually gonna release some some
phosphorus there so that's kind of where
that's gets that from cow peas warm
season broadleaf not not frost tolerant
whatsoever but it likes it hot and dry
so you guys in August I mean if you
haven't planted timely you could throw
some copies in if you don't get them
planted up here by July 15th I would be
very hesitant throwing throwing cow peas
in there clear season grasses so I won't
spend a lot of time on these since we
grow a lot of them up here we know a lot
about rye barley very salt tolerant and
like that from that standpoint I do do
some with some barley and oats is
probably the biggest one that I add to
every mixture I always put 20% it's in
about 14 14 to 20 pounds depending if
you're going to be grazing it or not
fairly mycorrhizal does corn loves oats
you plant corn and oats double does very
well Trey Kelly a cross between Ryan
durum wheat spring and winter types we
got some guys messing with that that
sort of stuff anyway I guess I don't
think for the most part you and do a lot
of that just watch where you get your
seats
if you do try some of it just not one of
it's one of those cool season grasses
that I love the whoop system it's very
somewhat similar to test tough grass has
a very fine root system but it's just
very this is a very spindly plant in a
cover crop mixture and most of the guys
are using this over east and into Iowa
the other cover crop if you want to
start growing some seed Rye suruli and
we've used to raise some cereal right
when I was growing up up here I will
take all your cereal rye you want I
guarantee you that they use a lot of
cereal right down there one of season
grasses green and for sorghum millet
Sedan grass sorghum hybrids corn TIFF
grass we do a lot of these up here I'm
not going to spend a lot of time tough
grass is one that you probably haven't
heard a lot of once these annual grass
is very very small seeds generally and
it comes coated or uncoated to help with
the seeding process but anywhere from
three to eight pounds depending on the
thickness of the coat again a good root
system as far as being very fine getting
into small areas to help develop soil
structure yeah it's very good hay
quality very very good hay quality and
there's a number of guys in the pier
area some guys raised it for seed some
guys have raised it for just strictly
for hay get two or three cuttings off of
it and done quite well with it
now magic bait at least where I am at I
want Covercraft planted by August 5th
produces the most growth consistently
this window we've studied this for three
years
that window was two weeks either side of
that all the time some years this year
probably would have been the year you
could have got by with August 20th 25th
and then just fine we just don't know
secret is is what October is gonna be if
I knew what October was gonna be every
year I sure wouldn't be working for the
government but for the most part earlier
the better I have to get those
established there's just a picture in
McPherson County over there by Leola
turnip radish German military own 6,500
pounds of dry weight now other guys want
to bail these up so Ottoman bail them up
compared to dis grazing him North Dakota
study where they looked at grazing him
the following year raising him that fall
versus chopping him off looking at the
following year's cash crop impact on
yield grazing 91 bushel corn where they
chopped and remove the residue 68 bushel
corn removing that Armour is extremely
valuable now this is just like it's just
a quick study that I did on some corn
stalks I sampled the field November 1st
and it was graze this one field was
grazed right next to it about it less
than eighth mile away both of these
fields have been managed by the same guy
for the past 15 years and the soil tests
were taken unfortunately after grazing I
wish they would have had some so test
before the grazing period but the
producer was shocked looked at his own
to here 24 parts per million Olson here
compared to the ungrazed 11 again both
of these both of these were managed the
same way for the past 15 years that was
your one after Daisy your - after
grazing I thought that's a fluke never
going to happen again same thing again
they weren't graze that was sunflowers
this year the other field was grazed
this current year 18 compared to nine
still holding steady I wasn't a fluke
and actually held off her I have slices
I forgot to add them in this one but I
do have slides further for year three
and they were still there they're
getting closer together but it's still
higher for where it was grazed the
challenges are trained to figure out how
to mix these together to see them most
days with the air Cedars a lot easier if
you do happen to do maybe some larger
seat at fuel piece all of that chickling
vetch chickling vetch seed do you have
some of that here okay
the chick
vej she looks like Pete Rock and it's
bigger so you probably need to keep that
separate and put in a different tank and
with air cuts easier to do with a 750
drill a lot more difficult if that's all
you have a 750 drill I'd still throw
them all together put in there only feel
about half ways for because you know by
the time you get it empty dollar is
going to be started to get separated but
most guys just throw them in together
and this has been by far our best way to
establish cover crops we've did this
with a beet turnip truck and standing
wheat back in 2008 and we did this six
weeks be hard before harvest and it was
way too early way too early we got cover
crops to come and that wheat was still
too green got shaded out and they died
too early if you like broadcast
understanding wheat I would not do it
any more than maybe three weeks
beforehand preferably two but the
drilling method has been the best the
main issue with the drilling that I see
my part of the area with the biomass
that we have over there guys seed set
the drill to shallow most of time I tell
guys depending on how worn their discs
are is one notch less than wheat
possibly two notches less than wheat I
want you to cut through that residue
I've seen too many fields where the guys
started bright and early in the morning
a shitty stand nice nice stance starting
about 1/2 o'clock in the afternoon you
can tell right where is that lady
evening it goes back to crap again just
because they were not cutting through
this thick matter residue
I know these seeds are small but you
need to get them in the seed to soil
contact I'm not going to cover that but
we do have some termination guidelines
and it does affect this area area if you
do summer fallow and you try to put a
cover crop on summer fallow it does
affect this area because as of right now
RMA insurance says that that cover crop
needs to be terminated in 90 days before
planting that next crop okay so the guys
with fellow with winter wheat definitely
going to impact you the guys with fallow
going to spring wheat and
you may be able to get by with that but
check with NRCS we have this part of a
it's attached to a practice standard if
you're not familiar with it but one of
your offices know and they can get that
for you but in summary the benefits of
cover crops accrue over several years
you will see improvements in crop yield
pest management and soil tilth
if you commit to cover crop use whenever
and wherever possible in your rotation
and that's all I have so with that do I
have any questions so let's write that
for lunch I know it's just as hard for
me as if for you guys great
I got off easy